cracked Studios locked themselves inside
a house with a special guest at the
house in Nashville against cinemasins
the goal to make as many sketches as
possible this is one of them oh hey
Garrett here from this as a father of
teenagers myself I'm practically a
teenager myself and I like you I'm just
sick of all these dumb baby hangouts
I mean sure there's pizza and sure
they're good for getting the blow Jay or
a nice deep squeezer behind a copy of
Time Crisis two like I overheard my son
David talking about when I wasn't
invading his privacy I just want to be a
part of his life but you know are those
other places really places teens want to
hang I've said no many times before and
I'm finally filming it you guys to tell
you that you should all just do your
team stuff in Garry's game garage Series
game garage that is actually the entire
house and be certified like someone
who's been in college wants to be
officially a big children only zone and
hey dust yeah that's what they call us
adults in case you're not up on the
board which is what they call lingo they
call teens big children they call tweens
young beauties they call kids babies
they call babies pussy turns genes what
up guys that's not fun once you're here
you can hang out in one of at most
several rooms if you just wants to like
get away from me told what to do for
once right
we cool and we respect your privacy
unlike some you have Christie and Dave
over maybe like a little too much
especially on the weekends it was their
only chance to see their dad but his
unfinished basement is too boring in
dark and Sasha's mom's cut a whole bunch
of Serge online so I guess fuck me right
just come over send some snapchat news
with fuller stars quotes on them placing
pocket monsters scroll through tumblr
just do whatever is easy you want he'll
have a beer
cool if Gary's game garage that is
actually the entire house we've got free
Macklemore songs and a constant loop
plus frozen's let it go every hour on
the hour during our hourly blowj a
parade that my boy Dave would really
like that so tell them to come in out
here if you know it we've got games not
something quack like skee-ball pin the
boring thing go a minute I'm talking
games like Xbox starting small
controlled fires binding trying sex
drugs and alcohol and safe consequence
free environment we got to Xboxes yeah
yeah when you play a game tell me at the
prize table to get tickets for
all-you-can-eat decent pizza men trade
those tickets in the fun prizes like
looking at my cool knife collection or
skateboarding over some losers face I
don't know do it you want I'll do your
homework for you you also have access to
a really neat big climbing tree if
you're feeling misunderstood by society
or are just up for a good climb remember
when we used to climb together Chrissy
we're so happy this is that tree come
hang out have a birthday party how do
you like them basement in there if you
really want a ball pit we can discuss it
wow this place is fun
ah heck it all let's do a fall pit we're
doing it if Gary's games garage it's
actually the entire house you just all
stop going to carries game for us
actually the entire house if it got so
popular you can't control teams
just wanted to impress my kids my big
silver it's closed so case closed
forever the last 30 minutes this video
masturbating in I won't have enough time
to record over it also just please don't
watch it